This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个I-Heart播客。保证真实。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是Michael Easter。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析心理韧性、健身以及在这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
让自己经历一些磨难，你就会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《2%》。在《Look Back at it》播客中。从1979年说起，那对我来说是一个重要的时刻。84年对我来说也很重要。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是Sam J。我是Alex English。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，拆解当时发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何度过那段时光的。与我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员和最喜欢的作家一起。比如Mark Lamont Hill谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to.
请在IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人Kear Games。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行一些在其他任何地方都不太安全的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在与一位知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人穿着盔甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
请在AHA电台应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2023年，《单身汉》明星Clayton Eckerd被指控让人生下双胞胎。但怀孕似乎是一个骗局。Owens女士，你两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吧？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一群互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。还有两个男人也经历了同样的事情。Greg，一个女同性恋。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands.
Michael Mancini。我的大脑被震撼了。我是Stephanie Young。这是《Love Trapped》。Laura，Scottsdale警察局。随着节目的继续，Laura Owens终于面临了后果。请在Iheart电台应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。当一群女性发现她们都与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定采取行动。
I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the IHartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. I'm Jemma Spike and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for. our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. Guys, today we're
我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他不会逃脱惩罚的。他会得到他应得的报应。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。请在IHartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《The Girlfriends: Trust Me, Babe》。大家好。我是Jemma Spike，欢迎回到《The Psychology of Your 20s》，这是一个我们讨论20多岁时最大的变化、时刻和转变，以及它们对我们的心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。很高兴你能回来收听新的一集，当然，我们要剖析20多岁的心理。伙计们，今天我们
doing it old school. I'm not in the studio. I'm in my bedroom. You may even hear some like birds tweeting in the background throughout this episode. But yeah, I had this idea for this episode the other day. I've been really thinking a lot about what gets us stuck in our 20s. how to get out of it. And I thought, I'm just going to, I'm just going to record it. I'm just going to go back to how we used to do episodes and do a little bonus episode for you guys this weekend, in my bedroom, under the covers, into the mic. That is exactly what we're doing. And like I said, today we're talking about stuckness, why it is that we get so stuck in our 20s and kind of the five simple ways I've been thinking about a lot that we can get out of it. There are definitely
要用老派的方式来做。我不在录音室。我在我的卧室里。你甚至可能在这一集中听到背景里有鸟叫声。但是，是的，前几天我有了这一集的想法。我一直在思考是什么让我们在20多岁时陷入困境，以及如何摆脱它。我想，我只是要录下来。我要回到我们过去做节目的方式，这个周末为你们录制一期小小的特别节目，在我的卧室里，在被子里，对着麦克风。这就是我们正在做的。正如我所说，今天我们谈论的是“卡住”的感觉，为什么我们在20多岁时会感到如此困惑，以及我一直在思考的五种简单的摆脱方法。绝对有
I think very few feelings as frustrating as knowing you are not happy with your life, feeling restricted, feeling pessimistic, feeling hopeless, and at the same time, having no clue how to change it. Having no clue like what is even going on, what step in what direction do I take first, it is like claustrophobic is the best word I could use for it. And honestly, I think the longer you wait, um, the more entrenched. in the situation you can become. And it's not to say you won't ever get out of this situation, but I just think the more you begin to internalize the state as permanent, the more you begin to believe that this is just how my life is. And the harder it does become to change,
我认为很少有比知道自己对生活不满意、感到受限、感到悲观、感到绝望，同时又完全不知道如何改变它更令人沮丧的感觉了。完全不知道发生了什么，不知道第一步该往哪个方向走，这就像幽闭恐惧症，这是我能用的最好的词。老实说，我认为你等待的时间越长，你在这个处境中就陷得越深。这并不是说你永远无法摆脱这种处境，但我只是认为，你越开始将这种状态内化为永久的，你就越开始相信这就是我的生活。改变它就变得越困难，
the more this becomes a permanent part of your belief system. It's very easy to see why we feel this way, why we think that life is never going to be different. And I have to tell you that's false. It's false. Like you have the capacity to change your life. You have the ability to get yourself unstuck. And there are some really simple things that you could do literally today. Tomorrow, if you're a bit busy today, that there's so much easier than you think that are going to break the loop that you are in. I also want to say it is totally normal to feel stuck in your 20s. As hard as this feels on an individual level, and believe me, like I know, It's not a rare thing.
这越成为你信仰体系中永久的一部分。很容易理解为什么我们会有这种感觉，为什么我们认为生活永远不会改变。但我必须告诉你，那是错的。那是错的。你有能力改变你的生活。你有能力让自己摆脱困境。有一些非常简单的事情，你今天就可以做。明天，如果你今天有点忙的话，这些事情比你想象的要容易得多，它们会打破你所处的循环。我还想说，在20多岁时感到困惑是完全正常的。尽管这在个人层面上感觉很艰难，相信我，我知道，这不是什么稀奇事。
I think during this decade, so much is going on all at once, but also at the same time, so much is not happening that we wish could be happening. And this creates this parallel feeling that, like, everybody else's lives are moving forward. Everybody else is getting their shit together. We should know so much more about what we want to do and where we're going. And yet, you know, it's not happening for us. The only things that we're overwhelmed by are things that aren't, like are things that don't make us happy. And that's really where the stuck feeling comes from. Definitely circumstances
我认为在这个十年里，很多事情同时发生，但与此同时，很多我们希望发生的事情却没有发生。这创造了一种平行的感觉，好像其他人的生活都在向前迈进。其他人都把自己的生活打理得井井有条。我们应该更清楚自己想做什么，要去哪里。然而，你知道，这并没有发生在我们身上。我们唯一感到不知所措的事情是那些不让我们快乐的事情。这就是那种“卡住”的感觉的真正来源。当然，环境
contribute to this. Money, relationships, jobs, cities can make us feel stuck. But a hard truth is that sometimes what really gets us into this rut more than physical barriers or alongside physical barriers is waiting for life to change our circumstances for us. Feeling incapable of making the decisions that we know we need to make. Maybe because we just don't trust ourselves anymore. Maybe because we've been so caught up in like boredom and our routine and how life has been that it feels impossible to disrupt what just feels like the status quo. So that is what a lot of our tips are going to focus on today. Breaking this status quo kind of negativity, same old, same old loop so that you are allowed to expand in a new direction. This is by no means a fully comprehensive list. As I said, I'm just on my mic
会导致这种情况。金钱、人际关系、工作、城市都会让我们感到受限。但一个残酷的事实是，有时比物理障碍更让我们陷入这种困境的，或者与物理障碍并存的，是等待生活为我们改变环境。感到无法做出我们知道自己需要做出的决定。也许是因为我们不再信任自己了。也许是因为我们太沉迷于无聊和例行公事，以及生活一直以来的样子，以至于觉得打破现状是不可能的。所以这就是我们今天很多建议要关注的重点。打破这种现状的消极情绪，那种一成不变的循环，这样你才能向新的方向扩展。这绝不是一个详尽的清单。正如我所说，我只是在我的麦克风前
in my bedroom. This is just like a fun episode I just had to make. But I do think that these things will really, really help. And I do think that they offer a challenge for you and your mind and your psychology that will prove to really shift things for you in time. Let's start with my first thing. If you are feeling stuck right now, the first thing I need you to do is to map out the problem, map out the ideal future, and map out what you see to be the solutions. There is a very specific way that I do this. I'm a very visual person. And when I feel a roadblock in my life, especially one that's kind of been sitting there for like a couple weeks, a couple months, couple of years, this is the first thing I do.
在我的卧室里。这只是我必须制作的一期有趣的节目。但我确实认为这些事情真的会非常有帮助。而且我确实认为它们为你和你的心理提供了一个挑战，随着时间的推移，这将被证明真的会改变事情。让我们从第一件事开始。如果你现在感到困惑，我需要你做的第一件事是规划出问题，规划出理想的未来，并规划出你认为的解决方案。我有一种非常具体的方法来做这件事。我是一个非常视觉化的人。当我感到生活中遇到障碍时，尤其是那种已经存在了几周、几个月、几年的障碍，这是我做的第一件事。
I get a massive art book or a massive A3 piece of paper. I've even done it on like a poster board. Like, do you know when you were a kid and you had to make a poster on like tadpoles or something or how lemons can turn into energy? I don't know. And you'd get those massive post boards from like the, from the arts and craft store. Get one of those. Divide it into three columns. The first column, what I don't like about my life right now.
我拿一本巨大的艺术书或一张巨大的A3纸。我甚至在海报板上做过。你知道当你还是个孩子的时候，你必须做一个关于蝌蚪或者柠檬如何转化为能量之类的海报吗？我不知道。你会从艺术和工艺品商店买那些巨大的海报板。拿一个那样的。把它分成三列。第一列，我现在不喜欢我生活的什么地方。
A big list, bullet points. You can draw it if you want, but what do you not like about your life right now, specifically? Then you're going to go to the third column. You're going to skip the middle column for now. What do you want your life to be? If all your dreams came true, if all of the roadblocks were removed, in six months, three years, whatever timeline you want to give yourself, what does your dream life feel like, firstly, look like, secondly?
一个大列表，项目符号。如果你想的话，你可以画出来，但你现在具体不喜欢你生活的什么地方？然后你要去第三列。你现在先跳过中间那一列。你想要你的生活是什么样的？如果所有的梦想都成真了，如果所有的障碍都被清除了，在六个月、三年后，或者任何你想给自己的时间表里，你的梦想生活首先感觉是什么样的，其次看起来是什么样的？
And again, specific, what is the job you're working? What is the feeling you feel in your relationships? What does your friendship circle look like? like, what's the apartment or the house you're living in feel like? What are you doing to nourish yourself? How do you feel about your body? Dream Life column. We have that middle column free for a reason. This is the stuff that you genuinely think would make a difference. So basically, what is going to fix it? What is going to take you from column A to column C, not overnight, but in time? Basically brainstorm. Okay, what in my life?
再说一次，具体点，你从事什么工作？你在人际关系中有什么感觉？你的朋友圈是什么样的？你住的公寓或房子感觉如何？你正在做什么来滋养自己？你对自己的身体感觉如何？梦想生活列。我们留出中间那一列是有原因的。这些是你真正认为会带来改变的东西。所以基本上，什么能解决它？什么能让你从A列到C列，不是一夜之间，而是随着时间的推移？基本上进行头脑风暴。好吧，我生活中的什么
life actually needs changing and make it visual, make it obvious to you, make it this great big brainstorm of getting all of the doubt and all of the, all of the roadblocks out of your mind and onto the page. The reason I think that this is so valuable is, again, just that so often what gets us stuck is sitting on a problem in our mind, overthinking it, ruminating on it, thinking that that is finding solutions. The moment that you take all of those thoughts and put, put them visually, tangibly in front of you, it's so much becomes more clear. I also think that final column, that dream life column is so important. It's important to create a mental image or to have some kind of focus in your life of
实际上需要改变，让它视觉化，让它对你来说显而易见，让它成为一个伟大的头脑风暴，把所有的怀疑和所有的障碍从你的脑海中拿出来，写在纸上。我认为这之所以如此有价值，是因为我们经常陷入困境的原因是坐在脑海里思考一个问题，过度思考它，反复咀嚼它，认为这就是在寻找解决方案。当你把所有这些想法拿出来，视觉化地、切实地放在你面前时，很多事情就变得更清晰了。我也认为最后一列，那个梦想生活列非常重要。创建一个心理意象或在你的生活中有一个某种焦点是很重要的，
what you would actually strive towards. Feeling stuck is one thing. But often we get obsessed over the stuck feeling and not the outcome feeling. Like where do we actually want to go? So having a clear visual or I guess it's not verbal written idea of what it is is so valuable. I also think that it primes your brain not just to focus on the most drastic sides of the story, right? Not just to focus on how bad your life is right now. Not just to focus on how much do you want to change it and how all the fantasies for your life.
你实际上会努力追求什么。感到困惑是一回事。但我们经常沉迷于那种困惑的感觉，而不是结果的感觉。就像我们实际上想去哪里？所以有一个清晰的视觉，或者我想不是口头的，而是书面的想法是非常有价值的。我也认为它会引导你的大脑，不仅仅是关注故事中最剧烈的一面，对吧？不仅仅是关注你现在的生活有多糟糕。不仅仅是关注你有多想改变它，以及你对生活的所有幻想。
But the middle part. It says the middle part is just as important. What habits, what strategies do we need to implement to get from column, A to column C. And I just think it's like a very simple mind map plan to help you lay out the future, lay out the next few months, just lay out what's actually going wrong in your life and what you want to change. Okay, tip number two to kind of get you out of this stuck state, I need you to do something
而是中间部分。它说中间部分同样重要。我们需要实施什么习惯、什么策略才能从A列到C列。我只是认为这就像一个非常简单的思维导图计划，可以帮助你规划未来，规划接下来的几个月，只是规划出你生活中到底出了什么问题以及你想要改变什么。好的，第二个建议，为了让你摆脱这种困境，我需要你做一些
hard or create a challenge for yourself that you promise that you will work towards for the next six months. It can be whatever you want. It can be a creative challenge, it can be a physical challenge, it can be a rejection challenge of like, for the next six months, I'm going to get rejected like five times every single week. I know is just as good as a yes for me in building my tolerance for rejection. Just any kind of challenge that's like getting you out of your comfort zone that's giving you something to think about, to work towards, maybe to even obsess over to concentrate energy into
困难的事情，或者为你自己创造一个挑战，你承诺在接下来的六个月里为之努力。它可以是你想要的任何东西。它可以是一个创造性的挑战，可以是一个身体上的挑战，可以是一个拒绝挑战，比如在接下来的六个月里，我每周都要被拒绝五次。我知道对于我来说，拒绝和接受一样好，可以建立我对拒绝的耐受力。任何一种让你走出舒适区的挑战，给你一些思考、努力、甚至可能沉迷于其中的东西，把精力集中在
other than just what's going wrong. wrong. Feeling stuck, I think, is sometimes just that, right? Simply not having any forward movement in your life. I think that's genuinely the definition of stuck, no forward movement. So you cannot get out of this stuck state. Like, there is no magic pill. There is no fast forward button. At some point, you're going to have to do hard work and be uncomfortable and make hard decisions. If the first way you do that is something that you voluntarily choose. If the first way you do that is something that you're like, yeah, I'm going to do, like, I'm excited by this challenge. I think that's going to increase your tolerance for future discomfort. That just comes with having a life that is big and a life that
除了出了什么问题之外。我认为感到困惑有时就是那样，对吧？仅仅是你的生活中没有任何前进的动力。我认为这确实是“卡住”的定义，没有前进的动力。所以你无法摆脱这种困境。就像，没有魔法药丸。没有快进按钮。在某个时候，你将不得不做艰苦的工作，感到不舒服，并做出艰难的决定。如果这是你自愿选择的第一种方式。如果这是你觉得“是的，我要做，我对这个挑战感到兴奋”的第一种方式。我认为这将增加你对未来不适的耐受力。这只是拥有一个宏大的生活和一个
you, a life that you want. There is this amazing paper called, um, the case for friction. And it discusses how the most important thing that challenging ourselves does or setting a six month challenge does is teach our brain to start craving delayed gratification over immediate gratification. And this basically means that in the long term, our motivational systems begin to shift from chasing quick dopamine hits to valuing effort, patience, strategy, consistency, and long-term reward. That is the momentum we need. Nobody gets anywhere in life. Nobody gets out of a stuck state by just doing what they are used to do.
你想要的生活所带来的。有一篇很棒的论文叫《摩擦的理由》。它讨论了挑战自我或设定六个月的挑战所做的最重要的事情是教导我们的大脑开始渴望延迟满足而不是即时满足。这意味着从长远来看，我们的动机系统开始从追求快速的多巴胺刺激转向重视努力、耐心、策略、一致性和长期回报。这就是我们需要的那种动力。没有人能通过只做他们习惯做的事情而在生活中取得任何成就。
doing, we get out of a stuck state by getting hooked on bigger dreams and more sustained, larger personal reward rather than just like the instantaneous reward of comfort that can actually be quite constrictive, of routine that's actually not serving us. Or even we get stuck because we imagine all the things that we like to do, like in that first exercise, not realizing that fantasizing and thinking about the future in this romantic way, is a way we get dopamine. Like imagining a future that you really want is a dopamine hit in itself. And we can get very obsessed and very hooked on that kind of source
没有人能通过只做他们习惯做的事情摆脱困境，我们通过迷上更大的梦想和更持续、更大的个人回报来摆脱困境，而不是仅仅像舒适的即时回报那样，那实际上可能相当具有限制性，或者那种实际上并没有服务于我们的例行公事。甚至我们陷入困境是因为我们想象所有我们想做的事情，就像在第一个练习中那样，却没有意识到以这种浪漫的方式幻想和思考未来，是我们获得多巴胺的一种方式。就像想象一个你真正想要的未来本身就是一种多巴胺刺激。我们可以变得非常沉迷于那种来源
and that kind of input of good feelings from simply fantasizing and imagining. We need to convert that. We need to take those good feelings and turn them into action, turn it into forward movement, turn it into progress. And I thought that sounds like, many like cliche buzzwords, but essentially to rephrase it again, pick a six month challenge, say I'm going to work at this for six months. If at the end of six months, nothing's come of it,
以及那种仅仅通过幻想和想象带来的良好感觉的输入。我们需要转化它。我们需要把那些良好的感觉转化为行动，转化为前进的动力，转化为进步。我以为这听起来像许多陈词滥调的流行语，但本质上，再换一种说法，选择一个六个月的挑战，说我要为这个努力六个月。如果六个月结束时，什么都没有发生，
that's fine. The only purpose, the only thing it does is to shock you out of chasing short-term validation or short-term dopamine or short-term reward and shift your mind into seeing the value of chasing long-term reward, things that don't come easily that make your life better regardless. My next tip I think is probably one of the most important and one that I very rarely see people talk about. Stop asking everybody else for advice. If you are stuck right now, everybody else's opinions are not as helpful as you think they are. Because these people either care too much or really don't care at all to give you good advice. Either they care so much about you that they are imagining a life that they want for you
没关系。它唯一的目的，唯一的作用就是让你从追求短期认可、短期多巴胺或短期奖励中惊醒，并将你的思维转向去发现追求长期奖励的价值，那些虽然来之不易，但无论如何都能让你的生活变得更好的事物。我的下一个建议我认为可能是最重要的建议之一，而且我很少看到人们谈论它。停止向所有人寻求建议。如果你现在陷入困境，其他人的意见并不像你想象的那么有帮助。因为这些人要么太在乎你，要么根本不在乎，所以无法给你好的建议。他们要么是太在乎你，以至于他们为你想象出一种他们想要你过的生活，
that matches their idea of what success looks like or matches their idea of what security looks like that is never going to make you happy and they're going to start enforcing that on you. I'm like specifically thinking about like parents here. Or you know that people who are just like, yeah, and you should totally do that. You should do that because they're not living your life.
那种生活符合他们对成功的定义，或者符合他们对安全感的定义，但这永远不会让你快乐，而且他们会开始强迫你接受。我特别指的是父母。或者你知道的那些人，他们只是说，是的，你绝对应该那样做。你应该那样做，因为他们并没有在过你的生活。
They don't really like they might care about you. They might be your friend. They might even be your partner. But like either they're just going to agree with you or they're just going to. going to be like not genuinely thinking about whether that makes strategic sense for you. You know what you want to do. Like you do know.
他们并不真的——他们可能关心你。他们可能是你的朋友。他们甚至可能是你的伴侣。但他们要么只是会同意你的观点，要么只是不会真正去思考这对你来说是否有战略意义。你知道你想做什么。你确实知道。
Right? You know what your dream is. You know what your next step is. Constantly asking what others think is just a way of avoiding that because that dream feels a little bit too big. And it's just a way of avoiding it because like you know it's going to take hard work. You know it's probably going to mean you lose things. You're going to be exhausted.
对吧？你知道你的梦想是什么。你知道你的下一步是什么。不断询问别人的想法只是逃避梦想的一种方式，因为那个梦想感觉有点太大了。这只是逃避它的一种方式，因为你知道这需要努力工作。你知道这可能意味着你会失去一些东西。你会精疲力竭。
but the more you ask other people for their input, the more detached you come from that gut instinct and that intuition that is screaming at you, yelling at you, saying, this needs to change and this is how we're going to do it. Because I think we all have that gut instinct. I just think if you are feeling stuck right now, you actually don't need more input. You need more internal clarity.
但你越是向别人寻求意见，你就越会脱离那种直觉，那种在你内心尖叫、呐喊，告诉你“这需要改变，这就是我们要做的”的直觉。因为我认为我们都有那种直觉。我只是觉得如果你现在感到困境，你其实不需要更多的输入。你需要更多的内在清晰度。
And that really only comes from sitting deeply with yourself, reflecting deeply within yourself and then just taking any kind of action whether or not other people approve of it or not. In a very similar vein, getting unstuck means you have to spend less time online. It means you have to get off social media. I cannot express this enough. I deeply, I wish I had more of a vocab. to explain to you how much social media gets you, gets in the way of you figuring out your life. Again, because you are so bombarded by a million different examples of how everybody else is living
而这真的只能通过与自己深度相处、深度反思，然后采取任何行动来实现，无论别人是否赞同。同样地，摆脱困境意味着你必须减少上网时间。这意味着你必须远离社交媒体。我怎么强调都不为过。我深深地，我希望我有更多的词汇来向你解释社交媒体在多大程度上阻碍了你理清自己的生活。同样，因为你被一百万个关于别人如何生活的例子轰炸，
their lives. And all those different examples are giving you a different blueprint that is confusing you. Every single day you log in. Who logs in anymore? Every single day that you just open your phone and you scroll. It's like, this is how I change my life. I walk 10,000 steps a day. I did this and this and this. The next person is like, this is how I changed my life. I actually stopped exercising altogether and only focused on this. This is how I changed my life.
而所有这些不同的例子都在给你提供不同的蓝图，让你感到困惑。你每天登录。现在还有谁登录呢？你每天打开手机滚动屏幕。就像是，我是这样改变生活的。我每天走一万步。我做了这个和那个。下一个人说，我是这样改变生活的。我实际上完全停止了锻炼，只专注于这个。我是这样改变生活的。
I started doing this crazy diet or this crazy routine or this crazy general exercise or I quit my job or I went travel. You could genuinely find in one sitting on TikTok or Instagram 50 different examples of people trying to to convince you or sell you a life strategy that has worked for them that probably will not work for you. How can you figure out, just like that advice point as well, how can you figure out what you want in your life? If your thoughts are constantly being interrupted, intercepted, frazzled by what other people are doing. And I do think that's why we get so stuck is because we want the perfect path. We want to know that everything is going to work out. And so we do seek certainty in other people's lives and yeah in other people's opinions waiting for the moment
我开始做这个疯狂的饮食，或者这个疯狂的日常，或者这个疯狂的锻炼，或者我辞职了，或者我去旅行了。你真的可以在TikTok或Instagram上一次性找到50个不同的例子，人们试图说服你或向你推销一种对他们有效但可能对你无效的生活策略。你怎么能弄清楚，就像那个建议点一样，你怎么能弄清楚你想要什么生活？如果你的思想不断地被别人在做的事情所打断、拦截、搅乱。我确实认为这就是我们陷入困境的原因，因为我们想要完美的路径。我们想知道一切都会好起来。所以我们确实在别人的生活中寻求确定性，是的，在别人的意见中等待那一刻，
when we feel like okay that's the plan that makes sense this is the exact blueprint of things that I need to do and everything will work out for me because this person promised it or because it worked for this person and unfortunately I think it's just the truth of our 20s and the truth of existing um the only certainty we have is hindsight right nothing is going to be promised to you stop searching for like the certified plan for how you're going to fix your life and just move in a single direction. I also think another reason we get stuck and why social media gets us stuck is that it just wastes so many hours of our lives. And that is not a revolutionary statement. I feel like all of us know this. But genuinely, imagine how much you could get done with the time you spend
当我们觉得“好吧，那个计划有道理，这就是我需要做的确切蓝图，一切都会为我解决”，因为这个人承诺了，或者因为它对这个人有效。不幸的是，我认为这就是我们20多岁的真相，也是存在的真相，我们唯一拥有的确定性就是事后诸葛亮，对吧？没有什么会被承诺给你。停止寻找关于你如何修复生活的认证计划，只需朝着一个方向前进。我还认为我们陷入困境的另一个原因，以及社交媒体让我们陷入困境的原因，是它浪费了我们生命中太多的时间。这不是一个革命性的陈述。我觉得我们都知道这一点。但真的，想象一下，如果你把你花在社交媒体上的时间，
on social media. If you were to fill those hours with something that you felt connected to, personally. A big strategy for me that I've been doing quite a lot recently is I delete social media the moment I step into my door and I can re-download it when I'm out and about. But in my house, in my home, I really try and limit it or I really try and delete it for extended periods of time. because it's so easy to be sitting around, bored, feeling unmotivated, and to get that low level of reward from scrolling and from engaging in other people's lives. And it just doesn't help you. And there is so much space in those moments that is available for you to actually be doing
用来做一些你个人感到有联系的事情，你能完成多少事情。我最近一直在做的一个大策略是，我一进门就删除社交媒体，当我外出时可以重新下载。但在家里，我真的尽量限制它，或者我真的尽量长时间地删除它。因为坐在那里无聊、感到没有动力，并从滚动和参与别人的生活中获得那种低水平的奖励太容易了。这根本帮不了你。在那些时刻有太多的空间可供你真正去做
something that would be bettering yourself and to actually be doing something, even if it was just planning an adventure or planning a trip or just engaging with your hobbies that would help move the dial when it comes to your life. That actually brings me to tip number five. I kind of just mentioned it, but, and you know what, this should have been number one, because I feel like this is, this really is my favorite. I say this for every single one, but this is a guaranteed way to get you unstuck. Like guaranteed 100% effectiveness rate, go on more adventures.
一些能让你变得更好的事情，去做一些事情，即使只是计划一次冒险或计划一次旅行，或者只是参与你的爱好，这都有助于推动你生活的进展。这实际上引出了我的第五个建议。我刚才提到了，但是，你知道吗，这本应该是第一条，因为我觉得这是，这真的是我最喜欢的。我为每一个建议都这么说，但这是一种保证让你摆脱困境的方法。就像保证100%的有效率，去进行更多的冒险。
get out and about in the world, shake up your routine, shake up your life, shake up the status quote of what you do every single day. I feel like when we get stuck, we get into this negative loop, right? This negative loop of everything just going around and around and around, same thing every single day and the adventure, the insertion of adventure is the is the breaker, is the circuit breaker, is the thing that says, oh, we're actually not going to keep doing what we've always been doing today. Great. And your mind grabs onto that and your mind, we know this, loves novelty, loves newness, loves opportunities for new experiences. And it deeply and intensely expands how you see the world. It changes your neural networks. It changes your psychology because when you have
走出去，去看看世界，打破你的常规，打破你的生活，打破你每天所做的现状。我觉得当我们陷入困境时，我们进入了一个负面循环，对吧？这个负面循环让一切每天都在重复，每天都一样，而冒险，冒险的插入是打破者，是断路器，是那个说“哦，我们今天实际上不会继续做我们一直做的事情”的东西。太棒了。你的大脑抓住了这一点，你的大脑，我们知道这一点，喜欢新奇，喜欢新鲜感，喜欢新体验的机会。它深刻而强烈地扩展了你看待世界的方式。它改变了你的神经网络。它改变了你的心理，因为当你拥有
adventures, and I don't mean like of grand hike Machu Picchu, Summit Mount Everest Adventure. I mean like the adventure of going to the next town over and like, I don't know, going on a solo hike by yourself. I mean the adventure of a casual road trip. I mean the adventure of just like doing anything that is fun and that you can write a little bit of a story about and that lets you meet new people, lets you see new things that you usually wouldn't see, that opens doors for you. Mentally, physically, and most importantly, obviously, psychologically. Part of the reason we get stuck again is because we see the world and we believe it's always going to be that way.
冒险时，我指的不是那种宏大的徒步马丘比丘、攀登珠穆朗玛峰的冒险。我指的是去隔壁城镇，比如，我不知道，独自去徒步旅行的冒险。我指的是随意的公路旅行的冒险。我指的是做任何有趣的事情，你可以写一点故事，让你结识新朋友，让你看到你通常看不到的新事物，这为你打开了大门。在精神上，身体上，最重要的是，显然，心理上。我们再次陷入困境的部分原因是，因为我们看到世界，并相信它永远会是那样。
we see our lives and we've been so habituated to what they've always been like that we imagine that there is no future where they will not be the same. Giving your brain the opportunity, even the slightest chance to see what else is out there and to see how quickly you could make a decision and be up and going and having a great time is just really powerful. And I think just puts agency back into your hands for changing your life. Well, I think that's all we have time for. Like I said, this was a quick little fun episode for you guys for your weekend.
我们看到我们的生活，我们已经习惯了它们一直以来的样子，以至于我们想象没有一个未来它们会变得不同。给你的大脑一个机会，哪怕是哪怕一点点机会去看看外面还有什么，去看看你能多快做出决定并出发去度过一段美好时光，这真的很强大。而且我认为这确实把改变你生活的自主权交回到了你手中。好吧，我想我们只有这么多时间了。就像我说的，这对你们周末来说是一个快速有趣的小插曲。
I hope you enjoyed these tips. I hope they are helpful. Genuinely, that mind map tip, the first one I spoke about, is you could do it today and it will completely shift how you see your problems, at least give you some more clarity. So I would highly, highly suggest it. If you are really in a state of stuckness, a couple of the things that I would recommend. We have this episode called. how to feel like yourself again. I think it was released late last year that really goes into
我希望你喜欢这些建议。我希望它们有帮助。真的，那个思维导图建议，我说的第一个，你今天就可以做，它会完全改变你看待问题的方式，至少给你更多的清晰度。所以我强烈、强烈建议它。如果你真的处于困境中，我推荐几件事。我们有一集叫做“如何再次找回自我”。我想是去年年底发布的，它真的深入探讨了
this in more depth about how to get back to the core parts of your personality and the core parts of yourself that will allow you to trust your instincts more when it comes to making choices. There is also a book that I would recommend called The Anatomy of a Breakthrough by Dr. Adam Alter, who is a dream guest of the podcast, would love to have him on at some stage, but is a powerful book, is a fantastic book, and I think we'll give you a lot more, a lot more of a guide to understanding friction points and to understanding whether it is a mentality or a physical circumstances that is keeping yourself stuck. Because I feel like for this episode, we really only spoke about when it is a mental roadblock, but he talks a lot more about the combination of a
这一点，关于如何回到你个性的核心部分和你自己的核心部分，这将使你在做选择时能够更多地信任你的直觉。还有一本书我推荐，叫《突破的解剖学》，作者是Adam Alter博士，他是播客的梦想嘉宾，很想在某个阶段邀请他来，但这是一本强大的书，是一本很棒的书，我认为会给你更多，更多的指南来理解摩擦点，并理解是心态还是身体状况让你陷入困境。因为我觉得对于这一集，我们真的只谈到了心理障碍，但他谈论了更多关于心理和身体障碍的结合，
mental and a physical roadblock. So an amazing book, an amazing resource, I will leave a little link in the description below as well as that other episode I spoke about. But yeah, thanks for tuning in, guys. Make sure that you are following. Send this to a friend if you think they may need to hear it. You can also watch full episodes of the Psychology of Your 20s on Netflix, which is pretty cool, not this episode because this is just for my audio listeners, just for you guys.
所以这是一本很棒的书，一个很棒的资源，我会在下面的描述中留下一个小链接，以及我提到的另一集。但是，是的，感谢收听，伙计们。确保你关注了。如果你认为你的朋友可能需要听到它，请转发给他们。你也可以在Netflix上观看《你20多岁的心理学》的全集，这很酷，不是这一集，因为这只是给我的音频听众，只是给你们的。
But other episodes, like there's two a week on Netflix. Yeah, I don't know more to say. I need to get better at self-promotion. I realize that. Oh my God, look at me. Yeah, go watch it. Yeah, go check it out. It does really help the show. And it's a big thing for podcasts and a big thing, obviously, for our podcast as well. You can also follow us on Instagram. You can follow us on Substack. It's all going to be in the description. I feel like you guys are smart. You know where to find it. But until next time, be safe. Be kind. Be gentle to yourself. We will talk very, very soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
但其他剧集，比如Netflix上每周有两集。是的，我不知道还能说什么。我需要提高自我推销的能力。我意识到了。天哪，看看我。是的，去看看吧。是的，去看看。它确实对节目有帮助。这对播客来说是一件大事，显然对我们的播客也是一件大事。你也可以在Instagram上关注我们。你可以在Substack上关注我们。这一切都会在描述中。我觉得你们很聪明。你知道在哪里可以找到它。但直到下次，注意安全。要善良。对自己温柔一点。我们很快就会再谈。2%。这是当有自动扶梯时选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是Michael Easter。我在我的播客《2%》中。我分解了心理韧性、健身和在我们奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO.% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at a podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam Jay and I'm Alex English.
让自己经历一些磨难，你就会成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的人。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《2%》。那是TWO.%。回顾播客。从1979年开始，那对我来说是一个重要的时刻。84年对我来说很重要。我是Sam Jay，我是Alex English。
Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Game.
每一集，我们选择一年，拆解发生了什么，并试图弄清楚我们是如何度过它的。和我们的朋友、喜剧演员同行以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如Mark Lamont Hill谈论80年代。那是疯狂的一年。我不认为对黑人来说有比这更重要的一年。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《回顾它》。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？你们正在收听《艰难学习》，主持人是你最喜欢的治疗师Kear Game。
This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of, of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax.
这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行诚实的对话，在任何地方进行这些对话都不安全，但你正在与一位知道自己在做什么的持牌专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在AHA电台应用程序、Apple Podcast或任何你获取播客的地方收听《艰难学习》。2023年，单身汉明星Clayton Eckerd被指控生了双胞胎。但怀孕似乎是一个骗局。
You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. I'm Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm
你篡改了这个特定的测试两次，Owens女士，对吧？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一支互联网侦探大军来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。Greg，一个女同性恋。我是Michael Marantini。我的大脑被震撼了。我是
Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Traffed podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target.
Stephanie Young。这是《爱情陷阱》。Laura，Scottsdale警察局。随着季节的继续，Laura Owens终于面临后果。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《爱情陷阱》播客。当一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会时，她们采取了行动。我发誓，我将成为他的最后一个目标。
He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHeart radio app, Apple Podcast. or wherever you get your podcast. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
他不会逃脱惩罚的。他会得到他应得的。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友。收听《女朋友》。相信我，宝贝。在IHeart电台应用程序、Apple Podcast或任何你获取播客的地方。这是一个IHeart播客。保证是人类。此剧集尚无评论。点击转录中的任何句子以发表评论。